quarante-huit heures à haut risque pour
les forces de police à l'occasion
d'angleterre colombie demain à lens et
allemagne rend ce soir à montpellier où
plus de 15 cents policiers et gendarmes
sont mobilisés la france qualifiée pour
les huitièmes de finale rencontrera le
paraguay a priori une équipe à la portée
des français mais il faut s'en méfier
car elle a réalisé un excellent premier
tour le chanteur algérien lounès matoub
a été assassiné par un commando
islamiste près de son village en kabylie
aujourd'hui
bruxelles n'est pas d'accord avec le
tarif famille nombreuse de la sncf ces
réductions sont une exception française
qui pourrait être remise en cause madame
monsieur bonsoir
en algérie le taureau le terrorisme au
quotidien a fait une victime symbole
aujourd'hui cette fois ci c'est un
artiste le chanteur lounès matoub qui a
été assassiné près de son village en
kabylie sur une route où il avait été
arrêté par un faux barrage de police
le chanteur engagé politiquement contre
les terroristes islamistes avait déjà
été enlevée une première fois par un
groupe du gia 7 et en 1994
thierry thulliez cette hâte au lendemain
de sa libération fin 94 et tizi ouzou il
avait fêté comme un héros enlevé par un
groupe islamique armé quinze jours
auparavant
lounès matoub savourer à nouveau la
liberté il confiait à une de nos équipes
et terribles conditions de sa détention
je conduis moi j'ai eu un fusil parce
que j'étais quand même j'ai comparu
devant un tribunal islamique donc selon
eux j'étais passible de la peine de mort
soit dans mes chansons ou soit dans les
déclarations officielles ou
lounès matoub était plus qu'un chanteur
vedette
il était aussi un militant de la cause
berbère est un farouche opposant à
l'intégrisme et sur ses terres avec
laquelle on ne peut pas comprise au
jaune et moi personnellement je refuse
le dialogue et je me battrai jusqu'à la
fin de mes jours cours pour 7 comparé
cet inconscient il existe
il aimait tellement son pays qu'il était
revenu dans sa kabylie natale
c'est là près de son village qu'il a été
assassiné et c'est pas quelqu'un qui se
cachait donc élan il aura battu est donc
dans un guet-apens à lui avait mis en
garde rapprochée mais à partir du moment
où il s'est marié il est vrai qu il
allait figé d'avoir la garde rapprochée
parce que ça lui peser ces chansons
étaient à l'image de l'homme ces paroles
dérangeait c'était un très grand
chanteur qu'elle avait le verbe acéré et
à ses chroniques et c'est quelqu'un qui
ne mâche jamais ses mots ce soir en
algérie comme un pari ses amis sont en
deuil
l'assassinât de ce symbole vient
rappeler que l'algérie est loin d'en
avoir fini avec les violences le
président jacques chirac eux s'est
déclaré consterné par cette tragédie ce
lâche assassinat at-il dit suscite
l'indignation de tous les gens civilisés
où le monde de football 48 heures à haut
risque pour les forces de police avec ce
soir à montpellier
l'iran contre l'allemagne et demain soir
à lens le match angleterre colombie la
police attend là-bas au moins 10000
anglais sans billet même s'ils ne sont
pas tous des hooligans en puissance des
le débarquement à calais policiers
français assistés de leurs collègues
anglais ont bien l'intention de faire
une certaine forme de tri d'autant que
des hooligans allemands sont également
attendus venant de belgique
pour ce qui concerne l'agression contre
le gendarme daniel nivel qui demeurent
dans le coma l' enquête progresse après
l'arrestation de deux ligues en allemand
un troisième voire plusieurs autres ont
été repérées sur une photo prise sur le
vif
marianne masse à la location 22h30 hier
soir commissariat de lens une maman
vient rechercher son fils l'un des
témoins essentiels de l'agression contre
le gendarme nivelles
un jeune autrichien qui a pris en photo
plusieurs phases et gestes des hooligans
allemands grâce aux clichés grâce aussi
au signalement qu'il a donné à la police
il a contribué à identifier un troisième
hooligans incertain
andré 27 ans déjà répertoriés à
düsseldorf dans un fichier sur les
hooligans violent d'après le journal
bild qui a publié les clichés du gran de
lens ce troisième homme aurait été
reconnu sur une photo prise à paris
là bas ils auraient été brièvement
interpellés après des troubles en marge
du mondial puis relâché ce soir les
policiers français continuent leurs
investigations mais ne confirme pas
l'identité de ce troisième homme ils
attendent de pouvoir croiser des
renseignements avec leurs homologues
allemands ce qui semble de plus en plus
avéré c'est l'existence de deux voire
trois autres complices l'enquêté sera
longue
sécurité renforcée faut renforcer pardon
ce soir donc à montpellier pour le match
allemagne iran 15 cents policiers et
gendarmes ont été mobilisés mais aussi
des contrôles en amont sur les routes
venant d'allemagne où circulaient des
autocars et des voitures particulières
en direction de montpellier les
contrôles ont été multipliés christine
beauce sylvain gauthier des contrôles
comme celui ci la police allemande en
effectué des milliers depuis hier le
long de la frontière avec la france
cible privilégiée les policiers les
jeunes allemands âgés de 16 à 30 ans
leur voiture est fouillé de fond en
comble billet pour la coupe du monde ou
pas finalement je trouve ça normal c'est
drôle parce que c'est terrible ce qui
s'est passé à lens c'est très grave pour
empêcher la violence par ces contrôles
jeannie 3,4 car seul qu'il faut ça mon
avion sont déjà montpellier ils peuvent
recommencer à casser et pourtant ce
déploiement exceptionnel de 800
policiers le long de la frontière a
permis d'intercepter de refouler
plusieurs hooligans salma qui
s'apprêtait à se rendre à montpellier
hier après midi nous avons arrêté deux
jeunes gens de karlsruhe qui se rendait
à montpellier ils étaient en possession
de plusieurs couteaux d'un marteau et
d'un poing américain
les objets ont été saisis et nous leur
avons signifié l'interdiction de se
rendre en france on en toute la durée de
la coupe du monde
un dispositif similaire sera renouvelé
lors de chaque match que disputera
l'équipe allemande sur le terrain
maintenant de nouvelles qualifications
cet après-midi les pays bas et le
mexique qui ont fait match nul et 1
éliminé de marque la belgique qui n'a
pas réussi à battre la corée du sud
christelle bertrand parfois le football
c'est mathématique
avant 16h l'équation est simple les pays
bas et le mexique sont qualifiés pour la
belgique
le problème est plus compliqué il faut
battre la corée du sud et compter sur
une défaite du mexique
d'entrée de jeu les hollandais domine
quatre minutes après le coup d'envoi
philippe kokou ouvre le score au parc
des princes la logique est aussi
respectée
les belges prennent davantage nilis
profitent du rebond et marque
à ce moment là la belgique est qualifié
mais nilis sait qu'il vaut mieux ne pas
trop s'emballer
à saint-etienne le deuxième but
hollandais consolide à distance la
qualification belge à paris c'est
l'heure de la sieste
les diables rouges de nous il n'y a plus
de suspense mais à 17h28 tout le monde
se réveille à corps et s'accroche et
égalise
les belges ne sont plus qualifiés
les coréens n'ont jamais gagné un match
en coupe du monde avec ce but il sauve
l'honneur quatre minutes plus tard les
mexicains en font de même
les pays bas mènent encore 2 1
la fin du match approche dernière action
dernière relance et dernières secondes
du match
le mexique égalise hernandez qualifie
son équipe pour les huitièmes de finale
au parc des princes les belges sont
effondrés les diables rouges sont
éliminés on peut se tromper mais on a
l'obligation de s'excuser larbitre
américain de brésil norvège ne s'était
pas trompé lui il y avait bien penalty
contre le brésil à la dernière minute un
document me prouve françois brabant à
tout se loue compris qu'ils avaient
affirmé que la victoire de la norvège
était tirée par les cheveux
voici la réponse
quelque chose a bien été tiré mais c'est
le maillot dottore andré flo cette image
prise de derrière le but du brésil ne
laisse aucun doute y avait bien penalty
pourtant ce soir là on n'a pas été
nombreux à la corde et à vitesse normale
ça allait trop vite pour nous sur le
premier ralenti on arrive après la faute
et sur le deuxième aussi bref nous on
n'avait pas sifflé penalty on a préféré
sifflet monsieur barmasse larbitre
l'américain forcément un culte en
football monsieur bart masque qui a vu
ce que dit cette caméra n'avait pas pu
montrer qui n'a pas eu peur du brésil et
des brésiliens que beaucoup nous compris
aurait bien tiré hors du mondial
mais voilà si quelque chose a bien été
tiré c'est le maillot de torts et andré
flo larbitre l'avait vu justice lui soit
rendue à lui et à la norvège qui n'a pas
du tout tricher et nous a incité ce soir
à un peu plus d'humilité leur parle de
la ténébreuse affaire de billets volés
la semaine dernière chez un tour
opérateur américain à paris d'entreprise
avait déclaré souvenez vous un
cambriolage et la disparition de 15
cents billets plus une somme de 1 plus
de 3 millions de francs aujourd'hui on a
appris que quatre personnes étaient
placées en garde à vue parmi lesquels
des dirigeants de cette société thibault
de barbeyrac guillon faudra derrière cet
échafaudage un immeuble que les
policiers fréquente régulièrement depuis
quelques jours ici se trouve le siège
parisien d'un tour opérateur américain
transport international un tour operator
chargée de commercialiser quarante mille
billets de la coupe du monde
mais selon des supporters brésiliens et
vénézuélien freins sport n'aurait pas
livré tous les billets qui lui ont été
commandés la police commence à
s'intéresser à la faire lorsque coup de
théâtre la semaine dernière les locaux
sont cambriolés les voleurs seraient
passés par l'échafaudage et selon le
tour operator 3 millions 300 mille
francs et 15 mille billets ont disparu
du corps le lendemain le comité français
d'organisation de la coupe du monde
dubitatif se demande si les billets
volés ont vraiment existé
ce matin les policiers ont placé quatre
personnes en garde à vue parmi lesquels
des dirigeants de prime sport
international
les enquêteurs veulent vérifier que le
tour operator n'est pas vendu plus de
billets qu'il n'en posséder des
enquêteurs qui s'interroge aussi sur la
réalité du cambriolage bernard tapie
devant la cour de cassation aujourd'hui
il faisait appel de sa condamnation à 18
mois de prison dont six mois ferme pour
fraude fiscale dans la gestion de son
yacht le phocéa l'avocat général a
demandé que ce pourvoi soit rejetée
l'arrêt sera officiellement dû le 2
juillet prochain bernard tapie pourrait
donc retourner de nouveau en prison
l'europe et ses lois supranationale se
met en place on s'aperçoit à chaque jour
c'était avec les chasseurs hier et
aujourd'hui avec les réductions
accordées en france par la sncf pour les
familles nombreuses bruxelles entend
mettre fin à cette exception france
damien thévenot jacques jégou plus on a
d'enfants et - le train est cher c'est
le principe de la carte famille
nombreuse trois enfants 30 % de
réduction
quatre enfants 40% 5 enfants 50% 6
enfants et plus 75% un avantage menacé
par la commission européenne
les familles proteste j'ai pas très
facile de voyager quand on est avec des
bagages avec des enfants si on le
pressent et coeuve on n'a pas d'autre
moyen et
c'est une mauvaise estime il faut la
maintenir et au comptant et devrait
peut-être l'étendre à toute l'europe
autorise de la supprimer
la carte est attribuée aux français
quelle que soit leur lieu de résidence
ou aux européens
habitant en france bruxelles considère
que l'avantagé discriminatoire par
rapport aux européens travaillant en
france sans y résider
elle demande donc la suppression de la
carte pas d'accord
répondent les associations c'est
précisément il ya une raison valable au
maintien de ses tarifs famille nombreuse
c'est qu'ils sont un élément de
politique familiale domaine réservé
sizeranne chaque état c'est aussi
l'argument du ministre des transports
jean claude gayssot considère que la
carte s'assimile à une prestation
familiale au même titre que le biais
annuel de congés payés la carte famille
nombreuse et financé par l'état donc n'a
rien à voir avec les avantages purement
commerciaux consentis par la sncf
le gouvernement français a jusqu'à fin
juillet pour défendre cet argument à
bruxelles
derrière lui le sort d'un million et
demi de familles titulaires de la
précieuse carte
les assises nationales des déchets
viennent de se tenir à jeun chaque année
faut savoir que 13 millions de français
s'intéressent au tri sélectif des
déchets et leur recyclage et à leur
valorisation est de plus en plus de
communes cherchent à mettre en place un
tri sélectif pour ce faire et bien il
faut commencer d'abord par éduquer le
consommateur consignes et jacques genre
leur mission convaincre les habitants de
la cité des coteaux de trier leurs
déchets à commencer par la locataire de
cet appartement qui n'a pas le temps de
les écouter mais qui de toute évidence
ne pratique pas le tri sélectif
j'ai vu la north vancouver avait une
bouteille plastique aussi regarder des
emballages en carton c'est du tout bon
vous savez que je crois qu'à plus de 70%
des six gaillards y est les deux
ambassadrices du tri ont une alliée la
gardienne à elles trois elles assurent
une information directe auprès des
habitants qui vaut mieux que tous les
prospectus ou affichettes je me rends
compte quand il ya du vert dans les
poubelles ou du plastique du papier tout
s'annule dans deux des fois j'arrive à
savoir qui c'est donc j'en vois les
ambassadrices je sais personne depuis un
an elles défendent le principe du tri en
porte à porte et en général elle
rencontre des habitants intéressés
il demande parfois à quoi ça sert mais
participe autres et parce qu'ils ont
l'impression d'un de s'intéresser plus à
leur environnement que tout soit propre
nous on est un quartier chic on est
quand même bien on est la zup mais on
est un quartier chez entrée confirmation
au centre de tri de mulhouse le quartier
des coteaux pourtant considéré comme un
quartier difficile est plutôt performant
la collecte sélective les plus réservées
aux zones pavillonnaires elle est
aujourd'hui pratiquée par toutes sortes
de communes au nombre de dix mille en
france l'assemblée nationale a adopté en
première lecture le nouveau mode
d'élection au conseil régionaux il
s'agit d'éviter ce qui s'est passé au
mois de mars dernier des majorité
introuvable
pour autant la réforme ne satisfait pour
l'instant que le parti socialiste jean
baptiste banane seuls les socialistes
ont voté la modification du mode de
scrutin régional
car sur ce vote les alliés du ps n'ont
pas suivi point de désaccord le seuil de
10% des voix au premier tour n'est fait
faire pour se maintenir au second
les tractations entre gouvernements et
communistes n'ont pas abouti et avant le
vote dans l'hémicycle
on est passé à l' échange de propos
aigres-doux il n'est pas question que
l'union à laquelle nous sommes attachés
se fasse sous la contrainte d'une loi
je mets en garde prendre le vertige
hégémonique eux on sait ce que ça peut
donner
s'il vous plaît ne recommençons pas là
la cohésion de toute coalition implique
qu'on respecte les intérêts des
différentes composantes parti gaulliste
est nécessaire
et le parti socialiste est indispensable
donc voilà la loi adoptée hier soir fait
passer d'un scrutin de listes
départementales à des circonscriptions
régionales
le mandat des conseillers régionaux et
réduit de six à cinq ans désormais il y
aura deux tours de scrutin une prime
majoritaire donnera un quart des sièges
à la liste arrivée en tête pour accéder
au second tour il faudra donc d'abord
avoir obtenu 10% des voix
enfin la parité homme-femme est
recommandé pour la constitution des
listes
objectif affiché de la réforme prendre
les régions plus gouvernable mével aura
aussi un effet politique contraindre les
petites formations à s'allier aux plus
grosses actualités internationales
président américain bill clinton est
arrivée pour un voyage de plusieurs
jours en chine noyage politique voyages
officiels mais aussi très économique
il est à la tête d'une délégation
d'environ 1000 hommes d'affaires
américains faut dire que le marché
chinois de près d'un milliard et demi
d'habitants est encore en friche tout le
monde s'y précipitent la france
également
mais il faut savoir que pour faire des
affaires là bas et bien il faut concéder
un peu de son savoir faire un reportage
yannick letranchant philips la bbc
poussent comme des champignons
shenzhen sur les bords de la mer de
chine 3500 habitants il ya 15 ans trois
millions cinq aujourd'hui
pékin la capitale dix millions
d'habitants noyé dans un brouillard de
pollution
ici on construit jour et nuit la chine
affiche fièrement sa croissance annuelle
9%
cette vieille cimenterie usées
appartenait à l'état chinois
elle vient de changer de mains lafarge
le français en détient aujourd'hui 51%
mise aux normes augmentation de la
production sur 1500 ouvriers
on en a gardé 500
le grand dépoussiérage c'est la mission
depuis trois ans de lou ye yang
le directeur avant les ouvriers témoins
actifs pendant le travail par exemple
ils jouent aux cartes il buvait il
dormait maintenant ce genre de choses
n'existe plus avant n'était plus relax
maintenant le travail est plus stressant
rentabilité ou pas l'essentiel pour les
français comme pour les autres c'est de
s'installer les premiers les trois
gorges sur le fleuve yangtsé
un chantier gigantesque le plus imposant
barrage hydroélectrique au monde
l'objectif fournir de l'énergie bon
marché et réguler le cours capricieux du
fleuve 150 milliards de francs 13 ans de
travaux barrage décidée par les chinois
représentera 18 mégawatts
c'est à dire l'équivalent de 18 la
production de 18 centrales nucléaires
françaises il aura une longueur
d'environ 2 km une hauteur de chine
d'environ 120 mètres et vous avez ici
les emplacements des six premières
turbines et alternateurs hydraulique
le groupe alstom a emporté le marché
pour les turbines
pas facile pourtant de s'implanter
négociations serrées tracasseries
juridiques administratives règles du jeu
parfois fluctuant
sans compter l'obligation de livrer
quelques secrets le savoir faire
scientifique et technologique si nous
n'avons pas ici une politique de
transfert de technologie et de haute
technologie a confié en co développement
entre les chinois et les français
nous n'aurons pas demain d'autres
marchés mais la chine communiste
n'hésite pas à briser les partenariats
les mieux enraciner pour faire jouer la
concurrence à son avantage c'est ce que
les chinois appellent le socialisme de
marché
nouveau drame au pays basque espagnol
dans la banlieue de san sebastien
conseiller municipal de la majorité a
été tué dans l'explosion due
moto piégée sur un parking cet homme
politique est la sixième victime des
commandos séparatistes de l'êta depuis
le début de cette année 1998 le brillant
république jacques chirac a entrepris
une tournée en afrique australe une
région où le commerce et l'industrie
française ont un retard certain
rattraper ce voyage a commencé par une
escale en namibie où le chef de l'état
curieusement a été rattrapé par la coupe
du monde de football véronique sainte
olive jan cornet le township de katutura
aux alentours immédiats de la capitale
les séquelles de l'apartheid sont
toujours là mais aujourd'hui dans les
terrains vagues
on ne se bat plus que pour le ballon
dans ce pays d'un million et demi
d'habitants
la coupe du monde prime au coeur du
township le lycée jan janker accueille
les jeunes les plus pauvres aujourd'hui
ils ont cours de français et il parle
foot
d'après toi c'est le débat que serra
c'est le pastis ou même bien de ses neuf
là ont de la chance ils ont été
sélectionnés pour aller à paris
et la semaine prochaine ils
participeront à la coupe des moins de 18
ans et assisteront à un match au stade
de france
là bas pour jouer au football et montrer
que le namibien ne sont pas des métiers
ils sont capables de jouer au foot
le président de la république est bien
de cet avis en visitant l'école cet
après midi il a tenu à poser pour la
photo de famille
lui aussi pense qu'il n'y a pas de
meilleur moyen que le foot pour faire
découvrir la france à ces jeunes
j'espère que vous allez passer un bon
séjour à paris pour en profiter demain
matin jacques chirac s'envole pour la
combustion d'accompagner d'une
soixantaine d'hommes d'affaires tous
souhaité ou remporter des liens avec ce
pays ibérique le plus prometteur et où
la france ne représente aujourd'hui 2 3%
de part de marché 23 morts dans la chute
d'une tribune d'un gymnase dans une
ville du nord de la russie dans le
caucase le public assistait à des
championnats de lutte lorsque le balcon
s'est écroulé 23 spectateurs donc sont
morts une quarantaine d'autres ont été
plus ou moins sérieusement blessé
la coupe du monde de football on connaît
donc désormais l'adversaire de la france
en 8e de finale dimanche à lens le
paraguay qualifié surprise aux dépens de
l'espagne la france n'a rencontré qu'une
seule fois cette équipe c'était il ya
bien longtemps 58 la coupe du monde se
dérouler en suède la france devait
terminer troisième en quarts de finale
elle avait passé sept buts à 3 au
paraguay
philippe visseyrias roger motte
ils n'en reviennent toujours pas les
commentateurs de la télévision
paraguayenne un but après 50 secondes de
jeu
deux autres tout aussi beau et au bout
du suspense voilà le paraguay vainqueur
du nigeria en huitièmes de finale de la
coupe du monde
du coup ses supporters s'y croit déjà le
paraguay est prêt pour aller jusqu'en
finale
et même si dieu le veut pour être
champion du monde c'est nous qui avons
le meilleur gardien de but du monde les
supporters paraguayens ne s'y trompe pas
si leur équipe en est là elle le doit
affronter luis chilavert une muraille
désigné meilleur gardien du monde ces
deux dernières années qu'il avait re
légende vivante au paraguay issus des
faubourgs d'asuncion
ce personnage médiatique vit aujourd'hui
en argentine mais il se veut toujours
près de ce petit peuple du paraguay qui
vénèrent son franc parler le corps comme
la pression ça n'existe pas dans le
football
la pression c'est ce que ressentent les
gens qui n'ont pas assez d'argent pour
nourrir leurs enfants à l'entraînement
qu'il avait re se prépare comme un
gardien de but mais il possède en plus
une botte secrète
spécialiste des coups francs il a déjà
marqué 27 fois sur coup de pied arrêté
il ya quelques jours face à la bulgarie
qui l'a vert aurait même pu devenir le
premier gardien buteur de la coupe du
monde autour de lui une équipe solidaire
qui entend bien défendre ses chances
face à la france ce sera une tâche très
difficile
peut-être devrons-nous suez des gouttes
de sang pour gagner ce match mais nous
avons confiance en nous une seule fois
la france a rencontré le paraguay
c'était en 1958 les bleus l'avaient
emporté 7 à 3 justo fontaine avait
marqué par trois fois les hommes d'aimé
jacquet aimerait bien que l'histoire se
répète aujourd'hui à l'issue des
éliminatoires on peut dire qu'il n'ya
plus vraiment de petites équipes on
vient de le voir tout de même dans le
camp de l'équipe de france on préfère
devoir affronter le paraguay que
l'espagne yann lavoix andré germa et
soudain tout devient bleue et c'est
comme cela tous les lendemains de match
la france vient faire connaissance avec
son équipe
aujourd'hui c'était à saint jean
d'ardières les joueurs ont fait un léger
entraînement en public ce public dont
ils ont tant besoin
après les matchs le lendemain ça nous
fait plaisir d'aller leur parlait
d'ailleurs céréales les bonnes affaires
des autographes quoi qu'il arrive la
rencontre avec avec nos supporters nous
fait vraiment plaisir
la rumeur a vécu bernard lama aurait
refusé d'être le gardien titulaire de
l'équipe de france face au danemark
ce matin il a fait son travail sur le
terrain et jeter un oeil noir aux
caméras alors jacquet sapeurs-pompiers
en chef à vie est un incendie l'équipe
de france tombe bien ça vous embête
peut-être si ça vous embête pas donc
pourquoi chercher des histoires qui
n'existe pas il ya une hiérarchie chacun
dans son rôle chacun dans son rôle et
dans sa position
ça marche bien souhaitons qu'il en aille
le plus loin possible tout le monstre
oeuvres où les premiers les bleus
regarde peu la télé même hier soir
beaucoup n'ont pas attendu devant leur
poste le nom de leur futur adversaire
pays ressort jolie su je crois qu'en
rentrant dans ma chambre et je pêchais
veilleur de nuit où quelqu'un qui était
là qu'il m'a fait signer un autographe
qui m'indique le le paraguay s'est
qualifié en battant le nigeria
et comme le dit si bien aimé jacquet de
cette équipe du paraguay en fait on ne
sait pas branché pas de chance pour vous
mesdemoiselles
les joueurs ont reçu hier soir après le
match la visite de leurs épouses
est ce leur a fait du bien disons au
moral on a pu accueillir impatience les
femmes
et certaines sont mieux ranger mille
d'autres thierry henry lui présente l
avantage des célibataires à l'occasion
de cette coupe du monde il y a les
téléspectateurs que nous sommes il y à
des spectateurs privilégiés
et puis puis par dont plusieurs dizaines
d'adolescents qui ont également la
chance d'être sur le terrain de côtoyer
leurs idoles
il s'agit des ramasseurs de balles
l'occasion pour nous de pénétrer dans
les coulisses de cette compétition
pascal golomer à pierre laurent
constants il manque encore un peu
d'assurance bien sûr mais c'est une
question d'entraînement les porte
drapeaux d'aujourd'hui avaient rendez
vous hier au parc des princes pour une
séance de répétition
ils viennent du monde entier invités
pour cinq jours en france par un des
grands sponsors de la coupe du monde
cinq jours de vacances pour sept minutes
de concentration on ne plaisante pas
avec le protocole pour les premiers
matches on pensait ne pas être prévue en
fin de compte les enfants sont
conscients de l'importance et les enjeux
de leur participation le jour du match
extraordinaire pour être respectueux de
tous les rites les ramasseurs de ballons
les ont rejoint aujourd'hui cinq heures
avant le match
eux aussi viennent du monde entier
amérique du sud pays bas irlande
allemagne italie
mais cette fois pas de répétition tout
se passe dans les vestiaires
hocine d'avant-match en ultime eric
chacun découvre le rôle jouera dans
quelques minutes
avec ou sans ballon
n'est pas toujours très clair alors on
passe aux cours particuliers voire aux
explications écrites enfants se
débrouillent
cette fois c'est l'heure les porte
drapeaux n'ont commis aucun impair
ils peuvent laisser la place aux petits
ramasseurs
bruno vay au grain derrière les buts
pour les derniers conseils avant le
début du match
début de la première mi temps les
minutes passent aucune faute à signaler
juste quelques frayeurs quelques
hésitations mais chacun joue son rôle à
la perfection
en tout dix stations
les connaisseurs apprécient
la jouer les supporters n'auront sans
doute rien remarqué mais les petits
ramasseurs ont fait un beau match cet
après midi au parc des princes ce soir
donc sur france 2 en direct de
montpellier l'allemagne donc qui est
opposé à l'iran pour une place
qualificative pour les huitièmes de
finale sur place 15 cents gendarmes
mobiles crs policiers ont été mobilisés
pour éviter tout débordement de la part
des hooligans allemands mais au
lamberton arnaud boot une poignée de
main entre un supporters allemands et un
crs français par dont la france le
message s'accompagne d'une petite
enveloppe pour le gendarme blessé à lens
5500 francs récoltés place de la comédie
en début d'après-midi et des supporters
excédés par les hooligans les séries qui
se fait happer par 5 un taux légal
ça fait mal ça fait mal au coeur donc on
peut faire comme dans la région où comme
dans les films de karaté
on peut jeter dans les pays au charbon à
les arrêter même si on en prend plein la
tête
pour éviter d'en arriver là les
policiers en tenue et les hommes des
brigades anticriminalité reste groupé
des physionomistes allemands ont fait le
déplacement avec leurs collègues
français
il observe la foule à la recherche et
hooligans n'est plus dangereux
pour l'instant quelques-uns ont été
repérés oui effectivement mais sans
élément significatif pouvoir pour cette
appellation la vente du pc de la
préfecture partent les ordres à
l'attention des 1500 policiers gendarmes
et pompiers
la journée a été calme et les policiers
allemands se veulent confiants on peut
pas prévoir
il n'y a pas de père soeur on est sûr
qu'il y en a mais ils vont se comporter
d'une toute autre manière par rapport à
lens ça sera pas la même chose ça sera
pas le même genre de comportement et
lorsque des milliers d'allemands et
iraniens danse sur le mépris qu on peut
espérer que la journée se termine comme
elle a commencé ce soir au même endroit
le match sera retransmis sur écrans
géants ont beaucoup marché contrôle
après contrôle ils atteignent enfin le
stade avec le sourire c'est l'essentiel
puis la disparition à l'âge de 89 ans du
comédien jean mercure et de sa femme est
également comédienne le couple a décidé
de mettre fin à ses jours dans leur
appartement
paris jean marc est hospitalisé dans un
établissement de nice en octobre dernier
l'acteur avait déjà été hospitalisé pour
une double pleurésie jean marais est âgé
de 84 ans et il vit et travaille à
vallauris avant de quitter pour laisser
place au football rappelle les
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 48 heures donc à haut risque pour
les forces de police à l'occasion
d'angleterre colombie demain a lancé
d'allemagne rend ce soir à montpellier
où plus de 15 cents policiers et
gendarmes ont été mobilisés
le chanteur algérien lounès matoub a été
assassiné par un commando islamiste
cela s'est passé aujourd'hui près de son
village en cabine
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
20h50 allemagne rend demain soir ici
même à 20h vous retrouverai béatrice
schönberg je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur la prochaine
au revoir